good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the good institute washington
the german cultural center
i'm here about austrain the director of
the good
institute washing thank you for coming
to this evening's event a special
welcome to our guests
ac grayling and christopher hitchens
who will debate professor grayling's new
book among the dead cities
and his deliberations on the moral
legacy
of allied area bombings in world war
ii why this debate in a german cultural
institute
i have to admit that i had doubts at
first
that this would be an appropriate venue
for this debate
and there were two reasons for my doubts
first in an emotional reaction
i felt shame because you see
i think that a person or a group of
persons
who committed atrocious crimes and
caused
unimaginable suffering to so many people
should not dwell on their own suffering
secondly some people might misuse
the arguments and conclusions in
professor grayling's book
as he himself is very much aware of
and in this context some other people
might be
suspicious of our motivation
for having this event here
please let me be very clear about this
nothing in professor grayling's book can
change
the historical evaluation of and the
judgment on
what germany and germans did during
the third race modern germany
would have to live for a long time with
its past
however never forgetting the history of
the last century
we and especially we at the good
institute
are committed to work for a common
future
hoping that certain things will never
happen again to achieve this
we want to learn from the past
and i hope tonight's debate will be one
opportunity
to think about what the moral questions
raised in professor grayling's book mean
for all of us today
i would like to thank walker and company
and the politics and prose bookstore
for suggesting this event and their
cooperation
in organizing it thank you for your
attention and now please welcome
george gibson with walker and company
save it save it for them my name is
george gibson and i am the publisher of
walker and company a
book publisher in new york city and i
also want to start out by thanking
erie barrett and and the good institute
and the wonderful
local bookstore you have here in
washington dc politics and prose for
sponsoring and hosting this event um
we had walker company have the honor of
this month of publishing
ac grayling's new book among the dead
cities
we have not and i should add at this
point to be fair to all of you but i
should add the word yet
we have not yet had the honor of ever
publishing christopher hitchens
but things in publishing are circular
and one never knows
though i like you no doubt have had the
pleasure of reading him for many many
years distinguishes anthony grayling for
me
anyway is his desire and ability
to make philosophy and the the deep and
often
open-ended questions it raises both
accessible
to ordinary people and relevant to their
daily lives
i don't know how this evening is going
to go but i do know that at some point
during this conversation
um the allied bombing of civilians in
world war ii
more than 60 years ago is going to be
connected to our world today
anthony grayling is a professor of
philosophy at birkbeck college at the
university of london
he is the author of many other books
including a biography of the great
french mathematician
and philosopher rene descartes which
walker will publish this october
he is a fellow of the world economic
forum
and he contributes regularly to a number
of publications including the economist
the financial times and the observer
and he is also a member of a regular
panel on the bbc world
international on on international
affairs
christopher hitchens i suspect needs
little introduction to the people in
this room
a prolific author journalist and critic
he is famously unafraid to have a strong
opinion
and equally unafraid to change that
opinion over time
when we created a short list of people
we wanted to approach
to have a dialogue with anthony he was
at the very top of the list and we're
thrilled that he
uh accepted um you therefore have before
you two of the most
engaging um and uh and and interesting
minds
um in the world today um and i will now
get out of their way and let you hear
them
um but before i do um let me just say
they will each speak
for about 15 minutes 15-20 minutes um
after which i'm sure they'll
they'll interact with each other and
then we'll take questions from the
audience
after that books will be available
outside and i suspect that
if you wanted to procure a signature or
an inscription
you could probably do so if that
appealed to you could i also ask that
you check to see that all your cell
phones are turned off
um and that you refrain from taking
photographs while they are speaking
um and now without further ado anthony
grayling
and then christopher hitchens i think
that's the order isn't that okay
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed george and uh
thank you so much to the ghetto
institute for hosting this
um i must begin by saying uh straight
away picking up a point that uh
dr ustrin made there um about the
uh delicate aspect of this particularly
in a setting like this from the allied
point of view that is from the point of
view the western allies the united
kingdom and the united states
and the second world war was a just war
a war that had to be fought
because it was being fought against
aggressors
and there were aggressors who um and was
known at the time and
uh more fully known afterwards uh
perpetrated some
horrendous atrocities some horrendous
crimes against humanity
and one of the greatest crimes that the
western allies could have
committed during the course of the war
would have been to lose it
and that's a point that i'm very alive
to and it's one that we have to bear in
mind when we
pre-sinned from the larger picture of
the war and look just at our own
consciences on the allied side of the
struggle to ask ourselves whether
everything that we did in it passes
muster from the moral point of view
uh is it really the case that all the
endeavors that we made
all the decisions that we made all the
actions we took in the course of that
war
um are unquestionably uh good ones from
the point of view of the overall aim of
the war
um now i should just say a little bit
about how i came to write the book as it
explains in a way the
the the conclusion that the book comes
to at the end
and when i was very small small boy what
i wanted to be was a
spitfire pilot in the battle of britain
this was a very common ambition on the
part of small boys
in the decade or two after the second
world war and there were some
difficulties like time travel and better
eyesight and things like that that
prevented me from
fulfilling this ambition so i did the
next best thing which was to read as
much as i possibly could about the air
war
um first of course about the the battle
of britain itself and then as time went
by i read more and more
about the the bombing war and almost
immediately
noted that there was a a a tone of doubt
a tone of uncertainty
in the historical accounts given almost
every historian of the bomber war
found it necessary to provide
justifications for
one important aspect of it namely that
aspect of it which involved
area bombing of urban centers the
deliberate and systematic targeting
of thousands of tons of bombs indeed
hundreds of thousands of tons of bombs
on civilian populations and
uh as soon as i noticed that there was
this uh equivocation it
felt to me as though here was something
that had been
too little discussed in a way too much
left to the concluding chapters of these
histories
and then i came across a remark in one
of them which said
this question whether it was right or
wrong to conduct
area bombing as opposed to tactical
bombing specific bombing of
genuine industrial military targets is a
question which we must leave to the
moral philosophers
and i thought well the day will come
when i i'll try to take up that
challenge and that's what i've done in
this book
and in order to take up that challenge
and in order to be scrupulously fair to
all sides of the argument about this i
felt it necessary to talk about the
history of the
area bombing campaigns which i've done
in the book
also to talk about the intentions and
the knowledge on the part of people who
conducted it
and that meant looking at the discussion
about bombing as a weapon of war
in the decades before the second world
war and i mean just to give you an
example one astonishing thing was that
in 1899 at a hague international
conference in the hague on
armaments and peace it was decided
by the international community present
there to outlaw
throwing hand grenades out of balloons
this is before there were aeroplanes
already it was clear coming up on the
horizon that developments in technology
were introducing uh
potential weapons and potential
strategies of war that could be
tremendously destructive and so as early
as that as early as the
19th century this endeavor first
endeavor was made
and all during the decades before the
second world war those 40
crucial years there were repeated
debates about bombing
and the experience of bombing for
example in the first world war
the germans launched a bombing campaign
against
the united kingdom they sent over
zeppelins and uh big
big airships and gotha bombers these uh
gigantic
bombing aircraft they killed about 1500
people
mainly as a result of inaccurate
navigation inaccurate bombing they
thought they were bombing a
um a munitions factory in liverpool
actually they were bombing a residential
district in foxton
and the result in the minds of people
in england itself was to be horrified at
the prospect
of bigger bombers and more of them with
more bombs on them
and the devastating effect that would
have on civilization indeed so
great was the fear at least on the part
of civilian minds
that in the peace conferences in geneva
during the 1920s and early 1930s
not only was an endeavor made to ban
bombing to outlaw bombing in war
but indeed it was at one point mooted
that flight
that airplanes should be banned on the
grounds that if there was one somebody
would throw a bomb out of it
well that didn't uh um
didn't persuade anybody largely because
the militaries at the time had
already grasped the potential of bombing
um
after all the british had been using it
very effectively in iraq or during the
1920s to police the recalcitrant
tribesmen there
and the person who was in command of
that bombing endeavour in iraq
was a man called arthur harris and
arthur harris was of that school of
thought
initiated by duhay and others that
bombing was an extremely potent weapon
which could
bring a war to an end very swiftly
because it would terrorize a
civilian population into persuading its
own government to give up the struggle
there were quite different thoughts
about about bombing rock bombing was for
and should be for
here in the united states of america
prior to the second world war
the united states army air force had
drew up plans for how it would conduct a
bombing campaign if it got involved
in a struggle in europe and they decided
that with
the smaller force and smaller bombers
targeting them
their endeavors at genuine bottlenecks
in transport in the production of
military equipment and aircraft
and very very crucially oil supplies
that they would be able to strangle the
the enemy war effort
and as it turned out and as the bombing
surveys found at the end of the second
world war
that was exactly right one of the great
contributions to winning the war in
europe was made by the united states
army air force
the mighty eight based in england and
the fifteenth based in italy
whose most of whose endeavors were uh
aimed at these
bottleneck targets and uh for for proof
if one needed it
one has only to think of the day on
which the soviet army crossed the
vistula river heading
westwards towards berlin they were met
by no fewer than twelve
thousand panzers waiting on the baron of
bridgehead
these uh highly maneuverable fast tanks
with uh
which packed a lot of tension which were
very well manned twelve thousand of them
waiting on the baron off bridgehead
not one of them could move because they
didn't have any petrol the fuel supplies
had been had been
severely interdicted by mainly by
american bombing
in the period beforehand
now when um the war uh
seemed imminent when people realized
that uh it was about to break
over the heads of people in europe and
this was from the mid-1930s onwards
the anxiety about the effect of bombing
was so great
that all the major governments of europe
put into place
plans um for how they would deal with it
in london for example
60 000 additional hospital beds were
provided
um something like a million uh uh
enough timber to to make a million
coffins
was set aside and in one of those
tremendous acts of futility that all
bureaucracies go in for
an extra five million death certificates
we issued to local authorities
and this is a measure in a way of of
what the anxiety was because of course
people
thought that on the very first day of
war a mighty fleet
would come across the channel and would
um bomb london
flat and there would be millions of
people trying to stream into the
countryside there would be chaos and and
there would be terror
and as it happened actually that mere
minutes after neville chamberlain
announced that the united kingdom was at
war with germany
the air raid alarms went off in london
because a solitary french pilot had
forgotten to file his flight plan
on the way across the channel but that
too was a measure of the anxiety
that people felt about it and against
the background of that anxiety neville
chamberlain twice
in the house of commons once before the
war began and once in the in the
so-called phony war period between the
actual outbreak of war in the 10th of
may when the
the germans attacked in the in the west
that twice said in the house of commons
his majesty majesty's government will
never bomb civilians
during the course of this war he
believed uh on the authority of of uh
his advisers that it was against
international law because
uh it was felt uh there but by
chamberlain's government as it was felt
here in the united states of america
that uh the discussions that had been
held
in the preceding decades in effect
amounted to something close
to customer international law and that
it would be a crime
uh in that law to bomb civilian targets
of course uh actually the motivation for
chamberlain saying what he did
about um not bombing civilian targets
was that uh
britain was very underprepared for the
war and terrified that a
great assault against the cities of the
united kingdom would be mounted
by germany and so he was trying to
persuade the germans not to do it by
saying that he wouldn't do it
so that was that was an important part
of the motivation but
it was sincere enough for obamacare to
be under
very strict instructions that its
aircraft should not
cross the coast of continental europe in
case a bomb fell out of an airplane and
onto a civilian
so the bomber command wasn't even
allowed to cross the coast before
the attack in the west on the 10th of
may 1940
and after that attack and right the way
up until february 1942
and despite the blitz which um about
which the the
certain things would be said because in
fact it wasn't itself a genuine area
bombing campaign it was an attempt to
paralyze the
financial administrative districts of
london and to paralyze the industrial
cities like coventry and
doc cities like plymouth and so on but
even despite that
bomber command was under orders not to
target civilian populations deliberately
until february 1942
but increasingly in the early years of
the war
there was more and more acceptance of
what we now call collateral damage
the fact that if you're attacking a a
military facility or or a factory in a
city
your bombs are going to fall on the
people who live nearby
and the anxiety about doing that early
in the war dissipated as the morning
mist does
with the sun coming up so that by the
time the infamous director of the 14th
february 1942 was sent to obama command
saying
your primary target from now on will be
the morale of the enemy population
by that time attitudes had changed
and i like to mention at this juncture
that uh you know sometimes people say
aren't you
isn't this all hindsight aren't you
looking back at the war and raising
questions about it from
the comfort of and relative safety of
your armchair now in the
early 21st century which my reply is
that two and a half thousand years ago
um thucydides in writing about the
peloponnesian war said
i want to recount the history of this
war in order to show
how moral sensibility is coursened by
war
how when you're engaged in the struggle
you care less and less as time
goes by about what you do and he gave as
uh
the the sort of killer example of this
the difference between the athenians
attitude to my tellini early in the war
maitelini was a city on lesbos which had
breached the treaty that it had with
athens and the athenians discussed the
question whether
in punishment they should massacre the
population of mychalini
uh if they had bombers they would have
done it that way but in those days they
didn't
they decided against it they decided not
to massacre the population mainly for
prudential reasons but the fact that
they had to debate it all
had behind it a moral impulse
but 12 years later when the city of
milos wouldn't play ball with athens
there was no debate the population was
massacred
and thucydides wanted people to be alert
to this fact of the courseling
effect of war and it's a lesson that
applies not just to the second world war
into the bomber story in that war
but uh to us at all points in our
history including
now anyway 14th of february 1942
the uh primary task of bomber command
was to
attack the morale of the enemy
population that meant
systematic and repeated attacks on urban
areas on civilian populations
with the express purpose of killing and
terrorizing as many of them as possible
because the um the kind of aircraft
like the big lancaster and halifax and
sterling four engine bombers which could
carry tremendous bomb loads
twice the bomb load of a b-17 flying
fortress
uh and the kind of weaponry because that
was still in
in process and it wasn't really until
1943 that uh sarva harris
had the the weapon that he wanted to
carry out this
anti-morale campaign against the german
population
it was only then in 1943 that the really
great raids happened
and the first of them was the um very
aptly named operation gomorrah
which took place in late july early
august 1943
and in which the very first fire storm
occurred it's been very eloquently
written about by w.g zabalt
in his uh essay the natural history of
destruction
and there he points out how many people
of the
about 40 000 people who were killed in
that one night were asphyxiated in their
cellars and in their air raid shelters
how many of them caught in the open in
the firestorm
were so severely burned that their
bodies shrank from adult size to the
size of babies or dolls
uh how many people were picked up by the
firestorm
burning and and flung away in the vortex
of these terrible winds
these were frightful frightful effects
of the bombing
and the point about them is that they
were deliberate because the royal air
force
thought very carefully about what its
bomb load would be like
it had 25 percent high explosives 75
percent in centuries
these incendiaries had an early form of
napalm petroleum jelly phosphorus
bituminous substances and oil soaked
rags
and the phosphorus if it splashed as it
did it was designed to splash over a
very wide area if it's splashed onto a
human being
that person would begin to burn very
fiercely and they might as
thousands of people did in hamburg throw
themselves into the canals to put out
the flames
only to find to their horror that when
they got out of the water it would
reignite spontaneously
it was a terrible collection of weapons
that were dropped
with the aim of doing as much harm as
possible to the civilian population
in those cities now these facts and that
they are they are terrible facts
could be counted by saying look war is
terrible
you know horrible things happen in war
and when it's a war to the death in a
war against a very formidable and wicked
enemy as the nazi regime was
um you know the gloves are off
and this has sometimes been very very
well expressed in a chilling phrase by
no less a person than mao zedong who
once said
war is not crochet and
everything that follows from that
follies and
when people say this to me my response
to them is to say
uh would that mean that it's okay in the
course of a war
to bayonet babies which is a sort of
shocking thought a shocking thing to say
and most people say well no of course
not
and most people would agree that
something like milai in
vietnam was a crime which implies that
there are limits
and that instantly raises the question
where do the limits lie
and it raises the further question was
the systematic bombing of civilian
populations in germany and japan
beyond the limits and to examine that
question and my the book is dedicated to
it and i haven't got much time
but but very very briefly what i have to
do and try to do in the book
is to look at the uh the argument that
says
um no it wasn't belong but beyond the
limits in the context of the war
that is that if there was a genuine
military necessity if it really helped
to win the war
then that fact trumps our moral scruples
about doing this
and so that becomes the key focus of the
discussion really
to ask whether it really did help to win
the war and the answer is
that it didn't people say that by by
bombing the cities keeping the workers
awake when when they weren't killed
making life difficult for the german
population and administration as a whole
because of the disruption caused by
bombing
that it must have done something to slow
down to dent
german production they must also of
course have kept forces back in germany
anti-aircraft forces
troops and aircraft to defend against
these attacks
the second of those two arguments can be
very quickly and simply met which is to
say
that no matter what you were bombing
even if you were bombing transport and
factories and
military installations and roads they
would have had to keep back
anti-aircraft guns and aircraft
so that doesn't defend area bombing
attacks on civilians
but as to the the question of industrial
production
industrial production of all kinds not
just military production
increased year-on-year in germany until
the end of 1944.
the german economy which was very very
strong by the time war broke out
and which as a result of conquest in
central and and eastern europe had vast
manpower resources vast natural
resources available to it
following those conquests was never put
on a war footing
it was never the case that a single
german woman was conscripted into a
factory to make weapons as was the case
for example in britain
there was so much labor that could be
drafted in from from eastern europe
slave labor and prisoner labor
that there was never any necessity for
it and production
of all things including luxury items and
bubble beds and flower pots and
all the rest of it went on and on right
until the end of 1944
and what stopped it was the drying up of
fuel coal
and oil and gas and that was the result
of attempts at precision bombing
tactical daylight bombing very dangerous
by the united united states army air
force we were only as it happens
those of you who've read about this will
know really effective from very late in
1943
and 1944 certainly onwards because of
the mustang fighter aircraft long-range
fighter aircraft could fly all the way
from
the east coast of england to berlin and
back
and could protect the bombers and it was
in fact the mustangs and lightnings that
accompanied the bomber fleets
which have fought the luftwaffe out of
the sky and d-day there were something
like 12 000 allied aircraft
uh in operation over france and
something like
800 luftbuffer aircraft to defend
against them
and so the the effect that that the
united states endeavors had
in the european theater was a very
considerable one
so that the major argument that the area
bombing that is bombing civilian
populations by night
was a major factor in uh helping to win
the war
um looks very questionable
now just to be brief because i'm sure
i'm running over time i must turn
attention to the american
endeavors in the pacific theater and
there i'm afraid
the united states went 180 degrees
in the opposite direction from what
they've done in the european theater
there's no question of precision bombing
in japan once the mariana islands had
been captured and airfields built there
so that the main islands of japan were
within range of the
of the pacific bombing force under the
direction of curtis lemay
uh a well-known name i think
there was hardly any japanese air force
left at that time and and precious
little anti-aircraft defense on the
ground in mainland japan and so curtis
de may told his flyers to
strip out the guns the the um defenses
of the aircraft themselves since they
just made the aircraft heavier
to fill them up with incendiary bombs
and to bomb from a low altitude
and to burn the cities of japan and this
he did systematically
in the last eight months or so nine
months of the war and the first great
incendiary attack was on tokyo on the
9th and 10th of march 1945
when 85 000 people were burned to death
in that city
i was told by um an email correspondent
just before i flew over
the atlantic to come here um about the
work that was done at the dugway proving
grounds in utah near salt lake city
prior to the bombing campaign over japan
where
replicas of wooden japanese houses were
built so that they could test which kind
of incendiary bomb
would burn it most effectively and so
the the the campaign was of course a
well thought out and deliberate one
and it was a tremendously destructive
one
in the um nine months or so of the of
the bombing of japan
as many people were killed and wounded
in japan among the civilian population
as were killed and wounded in germany by
bombing in the whole of the war
it's about 350 000 dead and about 800
000
injured in in both cases although the
figures of course obey approximately
and i suppose the final point about the
united states army air force endeavors
in the in the pacific theater is
that more than four months before the
atom bombs were dropped on the 6th 9th
of august 945
the japanese have begun to make
overtures for
a truce for a ceasefire they were doing
it through the russians who weren't at
that time at war with them
the russians only declared war in japan
on the 6th of august 1945 when it was
going to be an easy land grab you still
have some of the japanese islands as you
know
um and so the japanese made overtures to
the united states through
uh through the russians and there was
one condition and that was that they
could keep the emperor
you may remember that roosevelt and
churchill had decided casablanca that
there were to be no conditions and this
was used
some people say as an excuse by the
truman administration
not to talk to the japanese about a
ceasefire until the atom bombs have been
dropped
to the very very great credit of a man
called henry simpson who was secretary
of defense in the roosevelt
administration
he tried to dissuade truman from
dropping a bomb
on a populated city he said drop one of
them
on an uninhabited island to show what
the weapon can do
but his suggestion wasn't taken and so
he struck the word kyoto off the list of
possible targets of the atom bombs
because he knew of the significance of
that city
now i'm looking back on it now uh from
this perspective and this is my my final
point one notices
that in the immediate aftermath of the
war that is in the years of 1945 1949
tremendous endeavors were made by the
international community by the world as
a whole you might say
uh to try to put in place a framework of
of law or at the very least of
principles
which would make the things that have
happened during the course of the war
impossible i mean that was the uh that
that was the ideal that people set
themselves when they
um wrote and agreed upon the united
nations
declaration universal declaration of
human rights for example
and it was certainly the aim of the
fourth geneva convention which was
uh written and signed in 1949 the
convention on the protection of
civilians in war
that um convention in its draft form had
in it some clauses
which specifically protect civilians
from attacks by
bombing and the british and the
americans
refused to have those clauses included
because to agree to them would have been
a retrospective admission of guilt
of something that they'd done during the
course of the war
it wasn't until 1977 that a protocol was
added to that convention
specifically outlawing bombing attacks
on civilians
the british government signed it um your
own government
and i'm not entirely sure of the of the
the technicality it may be
that it was never signed by the united
states government or
has not been ratified by congress but it
generated not taken to be in force
from washington's point of view to this
day which makes this whole question
really about the
deliberate and systematic massacre
bombing of civilian populations
uh a live issue still during the war
itself by the way in the united kingdom
there was a very very vigorous campaign
of opposition to aerial bombing
um questions were asked in the house of
commons and in the house of lords
bishop bell of chichester repeatedly
said in the house of lords
we're fighting barbarians why are we
behaving like them too
and the mass observation unit which was
a polling organization in the uk that
kept its finger on the pulse of
public opinion during the war kept on
asking people in all
all around the country what they thought
about being bombed and about bombing and
whether we should
bomb in retaliation for the attacks on
on us and people
in the cities that have been badly
bombed majorities of people
in cities that have been badly bombed
said no don't bomb their cities
and people in cities that hadn't been
bombed at all said yes
bomb them and that's a very interesting
fact about attitudes at the time
there was full knowledge of what was
going on if you read newspaper reports
now
all the way through 1943 44 and 45 you
see
that um that there were very explicit
reports about what had been attacked how
many bombs had been dropped
there were headlines in the telegraph
newspaper for example saying
last night uh dusseldorf and brockman
received 60 coventries in other words a
bomb weight
60 times as great as had been received
in coventry in november 1940.
so people knew what was happening at the
time
uh the people who were running the
country had read their fucilities at
school and university and they knew the
arguments from two and a half thousand
years before all the way through the
great tradition of
uh ethical thinking in in the west
and so in many ways there are no places
to hide
except behind the arguments that i very
briefly alluded to and discussed a much
greater length in the book
about the the military and industrial
justifications that are proffered
in defense of the area bombing i don't
think those defenses work and i think
therefore
very serious question marks rise above
that campaign
and the reason why it's relevant to
discuss it today is because
although we don't i don't think that
there's much point in pointing fingers
and
calling people war criminals now after
the event
or indeed impugning the courage and
tremendous sacrifice that was made by
young airmen
in the war who thought rightly that they
were fighting a just war that they had
the support of their majority of the
populations behind them
there's no point in that but there is
every point in trying to draw lessons
from it for now
just when in our world we are beginning
to find ways of trying to enforce
some of these international instruments
that were the result
of the second world war like a human
rights framework and like the
protections of civilians in times of war
which because of the kinds of weapons
that we have now is ever more
important a question thank you very much
indeed
i'd like to thank you very much uh
ladies and gentlemen for coming my name
is like to
thank the goethe institute for inviting
me also
um i think i too should
respond a little to um
that's to say if oh my glasses on my
head
they were here a second ago oh you are
so kind thank you
i'm sorry this is not a throat clearing
um it's not a plea for
a plea for sympathy uh
i expected uh dr ustrin to say something
like that and for actually to take him
up on it professor grayling i should say
um i think it's time really that we said
look
uh we have been all of us very impressed
by the extreme seriousness
with which germany has accepted its
post-war responsibilities and discussed
them
in public in its own country and in
international forum
there is absolutely no reason at all to
suspect
that any reopening of this discussion
which has already been
quite elaborately uh
undertaken in germany even uh gunter
grass with his new novel of the crab
walk
has broken a few things that were once
to there's no reason at all to suspect
that germany would become intoxicated by
any uh vengeance
uh fantasy or any grievance or any
spurious
moral equivalence there's nothing to
apologize for in other words in the
opening of this
discussion and all of us british and
american i think should have said this a
long time ago
i very much congratulate uh professor
grayling on very lucid summary
of his own book that's not as easy to do
actually summarizing your own work as
some people might think
um and i don't i know he won't uh
penalize me for saying that much of the
argument was at least to some extent
familiar to some of you even if not at
the very elevated level
at which he presented it which enables
me to freeze me to
um propose a few ironic uh
references to it
um i was going to start where he ended
and i'll be brief by saying that
not only has this argument i mean york
friedrich in his book de bruyne this is
only the
most recent in germany but this time has
been going on in britain for a very long
time and did in fact begin i think
rather to the credit of my fellow
countrymen if i may say that
uh during the war not just to bishop
ralph bell of chichester who raised the
question in parliament as did others
um not just vera britain whose
extraordinary book
on the subject is still very much
imprinted very much debated
um but someone i'm proud to say was a
friend of mine the late tom dreiberg
actually he died in noble as lord
bradwell
socialist though he was was at the time
um a very important newspaper columnist
in london and in his column in the daily
express
revealed the case of a german girl named
hilda
who had been orphaned every single
person she knew
not just all her family everyone she
knew had gone and been burned to death
in the german city and he he opened his
column with a big picture of her
and the question right across the page
in 1944 i think
should we be bombing hilda and this was
a live discussion in parliament in the
church
uh in clubs and pubs and places of work
and in bomb cities
and it was right to have all these
qualms and misgivings then and if it was
right to have them then we don't need to
apologize for having them now
uh sir sorry zuckerman i remember
reading it this when i was
quite young very shocked lord charwell's
memorandum to winston churchill
saying i think i've worked out how we
could crack their morale what we need to
do is to find the working-class quarters
of the german cities where the houses
are packed closer together
and where we would get as it were as
americans would now vulgarly say more
bangs
for the buck we can really slaughter
them in these
working-class quarters lord charwell's
the
chilling uh memorandum of churchill so
sorry zuckerman one of the other
directors of this program
of bombing after the war wanted to write
a piece about it a reflection on it
for cyril connolly's great cultural
magazine uh horizon
and he decided on a visit to cologne
which was a city he'd had a hand in
flattening
and he came back and was interviewed
visited by somebody who said uh
well what about the piece he said i
can't do it i can't do anything about it
i've seen cologne now and i can't write
so what i can remember is seeing the
total destruction of the cathedral
and seeing a human finger on the top of
a pile of rubble
and i'm i've got writer's block about
the subject um
he said i had a title at least and the
title was
going to be on the natural history of
destruction uh later and next by the
great german writer w g
several who also mentioned who we were
very privileged to have amongst us
in britain for many decades as a writer
and a teacher
uh i stipulate therefore that i
absolutely know what professor grading
is talking about
and the most haunting thing in his book
i think is the one he didn't draw
attention to
which is this obama command and to some
extent
the united states army air force did
this to germany in the closing years of
the war for one reason above all
because they could do it they did it
because they could
they weren't able to do it earlier in
the war when it might
who knows i'm going to come to that have
made a difference but by this stage that
was what they knew how to do
had built the equipment for had trained
401st they were going to do it
it's not unlike the very gruesome moment
at the end of the first um
uh gulf war with saddam hussein actually
i believe that that was that's one long
war
myself i think it's been going on since
1991 and only
uh recently been concluded but let's
call it the first star wars 91 where
saddam's forces were were withdrawing
from kuwait
got themselves trapped in a huge traffic
jam with a lot of other stragglers as
you may remember in the mutual
pass on the way back to iraq that convoy
was bombed and staffed for days
for hours days by uh american fighters
and bombers who couldn't believe their
luck
from aircraft carriers anchored not far
away including the uss
ranger why did they blast them because
they could they didn't blast the
republican guard and was the pity they
didn't take out saddam hussein
was the pity but they could do this to
the iraqis and some kuwaitis too
well we have to live with this we have
to be intensely serious about it
i had to go and give a talk at the raf
club in london the other day on another
matter
and i i felt the qualm i always feel
when i go onto the premises of the ref
the picture of
marshall harris on the wall things of
this kind i was brought up to think of
fighter commanders the heroes as anthony
was
bomber command always been a bit more
difficult for us um but i have a
i have an anecdote i'm just going to
tell you now
which uh i think makes the history of
the raf
imperishable though most raf people
don't know about it
the midnight of the century as we old
comrades call it
the midnight of the century is the
hitler-style impact
the worst moment in the history of
civilization
the handshake between molotov and
riventrop the raising of the swastika
flag
over moscow airport the singing of the
horst vessel lead on moscow radio
uh the embrace of the two dictators the
crushing of poland
between them the destruction of the
baltic uh abolition really of the
boarding states
and the preparation for a ghastly war
well mr mortoff was back in berlin
because the alliance went on well into
the 40s as you know on one
balmy night in late 1940 early 1941 and
he had to take shelter
with his ghastly nazi hosts because the
raf
had arrived on a rather poultry raid but
it was enough to send the nazis
and their guests rather embarrassed down
into the shelter and while molotov was
there
with his nazi friends he said i thought
you'd told me this could not happen
i don't think the pilots knew how
brilliantly they had performed
on this occasion but if you allow
yourself to think about this rather
magnificent moment where it's britain's
airmen against hitler and stalin
combined
bring mantles the english cheek with a
great blush of pride
uh then you reflect on you have to you
are obliged to reflect on the following
two years before a group of germans who
when
we are known we we know them by their
some of them by their individual names
uh some of them by their um
collective name the chrysler group a
group of
very important german soldiers and
diplomats and officers
and civilian politicians grouped around
the heroic i think especially heroic
general helmet for malka um ludwig beck
was another member of it
and canaris was briefly a member i
believe at my old college in oxford we
had an annual commemoration for adam von
trot zusaltz who was a
another member of it later to give his
life hideously the
plot to kill hitler in 1944 they went
they sent an envoy to neville
chamberlain
and said if you and your foreign
minister mr halifax if you will
guarantee that you will stand by
czechoslovakia in other words if you
will say that in moving to
czechoslovakia
means war we can decapitate the nazi
regime and tell the german people
we have saved them not just from the
foul dictator
but from war as well that we have struck
for peace as well as for democracy
but we need your guarantee that you will
fight
for czechoslovakia before we connect
the risk this gentleman took in making
this move
is something that's very difficult to
imagine as a matter of quality and
bravery
and they were told forget it we like the
present situation in germany
we hope brother to make an alliance with
it against
stalin against communism and as trotsky
was the first to point out once they
made that
pact of munich with hitler ignoring the
opposition in germany
uh they made the hitler-style impact
inevitable
so that the whole might of britain and
air navy and military which was exerted
on hitler's side
in 1938 should later be used to bomb
and destroy german civilians is a
conclusion but it's
inescapable very slowly pointed out and
if you like impossible to live with
and to make it worse we find within a
few years of this
that the obliteration of the city of
dresden one of the most extraordinary
achievements of european civilization
the entire obliteration of it and most
of its people
is being justified for one reason and
one reason alone
if we do it it will impress joseph
stalin whose forces are pressing in
on the other end now i think if you're
going to destroy a cultural treasure
treasure house and and ignite a
firestorm that is designed to consume
all the people in it you had better have
a better reason than it might bring a
smile to joseph stalin's face
and this is not part of our official
history this is not what we're taught in
school
ladies and gentlemen in england my damn
inherent i can assure you
now um
how to confront these uh i hope i've
connected them for you
these multiple imbricated crimes and
ironies and
tragedies how to make sense of it the
way i propose to do it is this
by imagining myself not as an englishman
or an angry american but as a german
which i'd be proud to be in in fact on
my mother's side through
the city of breslau going back quite a
long way now
um i am i was brought up in the
immediate aftermath of the second world
war in plymouth
and portsmouth i remember being told not
to play on the bomber sites i remember
seeing
the ruins uh the smell that still went
on actually of the un
the un dug out uh collapsed buildings
and so i remember
i remember the devastation was it was
the scene of my upbringing i also
remember the
little island of malta where i was
partly brought up to which is almost
totally destroyed it's beautiful capital
valletta
almost completely destroyed by the air
forces of hitler and mussolini
especially remember the awful wreckage
of the of the royal opera house in the
center of the city but
and my father was a member of the royal
navy and had a very tough time
indeed in the north atlantic and
elsewhere um
on boxing day if you care
1942 his ship sank the shan horst
um which was about to undertake a
terrible campaign against civilian
shipping in the north sea it's a better
day's work than i've ever done i
mentioned it just in cases of interest
but in my heart and sinew
i feel german about this and if i can
commit the embarrassment of mentioning
the following names not in the same
breath of as my own of course
i hope i'll make my point i'm thinking
of thomas mann
i'm thinking of pastor niemola and duchy
bonhoeffer the great catholic the great
excuse of great protestant resistance of
france jaeger starter who was executed
rather than
join hitler's army as a catholic he was
an austrian i'm mentioning austrians to
ernst fisher
who broadcast from moscow against the
advances of the vermont
uh in russia um chancellors willie
brandt and bruno chryski who
left their own countries and joined the
uh armed forces of others rather than
surrender
to fascism kurt schumacher some of you
will know some of these names
all of them i think should be made
imperishable
in our history as well as that of
germany and austria and these of course
are heroes i'm talking about but how
many heroes
do you think that might have been who
will whose names we'll never know
in say hamburg a city that had always
withstood the national socialists
that had always remained as it were red
and democratic
how many people who carried within
themselves the seeds of a future germany
and better germany
were destroyed by the raf we used to
have
a question rather smug one in england
after the war where were all the good
germans all this time well one answer to
that i'm very sorry to say as many of
them were buried and burned alive by the
royal air force
and the fact has to be faced but
uh now look at it the other way
um we got billy wilder
albert einstein theodora dorno
marlena dietrich sigmund freud and the
germans got julius striker in exchange
for the
uh the collapse of civilization that was
undertaken by
nazism and i now come to another name uh
that of victor klemperer
can i just get an idea of how many of
you in the room know who i'm talking
about
oh that's admirable well for those on
c-span then
if i can uh media conscious hitchens um
victor klemperer the cousin i think of
the famous conductor otto was a german
jew convert to protestantism married to
a german protestant woman professor of
french
language and literature at the
university of dresden and on the first
day of the third reich he decided to
keep a diary and he kept it every single
day
until 1933 he's the only man whom we can
read of every
single day of the third right it's
called i will bear witness
don't start reading it late at night
would be my advice
do not start reading it later tonight
because you know what's coming and he
doesn't
so when they take away his cat because
aryan cats are not allowed to live in
partly jewish homes
seriously when they take away his job
when they take away his russian book
when they make him wear the star when
they say you can't now use the tram you
can't now use the bus
all this humiliation uh you know it's
going to get only steadily worse
and you're only encouraged by the fact
that almost every day he reports that a
member of the german working class comes
up to him and says
cheer up mate these bastards will soon
be gone don't worry we're with you
the scoundrels can't last much longer
the way he listens to the radio the way
he looks at the newspapers
uh the way he he disproves if you like
the daniel jonah goldhagen thesis which
i regard as a defamation of the german
people
and of their history the the the vile
collectivization of guilt that's
involved in the willing executioner
but the for all the friendship he's
shown
the machine grinds on and on and finally
it's come time to deport the last
element to the east
the ones who have aryan wives german
wives or husbands the last ones they get
round to
and he's moved into a holding camp in
the middle of president on i think the
night of the 12th of february
with his wife and the next day it's on
the train but that night the heavens
open
anyone who's reading account of what
happened in dresden that night doesn't
need any
words from me the terrible thing
according to frederick taylor's book is
the climatic conditions were even
better than they had hoped it succeeded
too well it wasn't just a firestorm it
was
i think it's justifiable to use the term
holocaust
which many people object to because it
means the total destruction of something
by fire i do not believe it should be
called a final solution
or an endless song as the germans would
say that would be
quite untrue but yes a massive
destruction by fire and in the morning
there's no authority in dresden anymore
and there's no one to take him to the
train with his wife
and they peel off their yellow stars
she's made to wear one too and they set
off
for their home and start looking for the
red army it's
over it's completely over there's no one
to give orders and there's no one who
will take them anymore
the only thing i think in our collective
experience and imagination that one
could call upon
is general sherman's decision to lay
waste to the confederacy
to make sure that not one brick is piled
upon another until it is understood who
is master now
and who has lost and to make that
conclusive
i think it would have been better if
anthony had dealt in his book
with the psychological effect of the
years
of the thousand year reich it had to be
utterly disproved that there was
a leader who was all-powerful and
all-knowing as so many were willing to
believe
it had to be conclusively shown that
when they said we will never allow
bomber in our own skies
that they were completely wrong do i
have a minute to read something from
thomas mann
yeah thomas mann wasn't jewish johnson
was not jewish
uh as you know but he decided he
couldn't live in germany under these
conditions and in
his great novel i think dr foster's
i think first 947 he he plays the part
of a german watching what's happening he
says
describing the the finnish germany of
the us
aaf and the raf he says this
earthshaking
plummeting havoc has come breathtakingly
close to my refuge several times now
the dreadful bombardment of the city of
jura and vilabel perkhamer was no longer
some distant event
and as the last judgment fell upon
munich as well i sat here in my study
turning ashen
shaking like the walls and doors of my
house
its famous publishing district is i
sadly hear only a heap of rubble and an
immeasurable wealth of literary and
educational material
is now the spoil of destruction a loss
not only for us germans
but also for a whole world that cares
about culture
that world however is apparently willing
to take the loss into the bargain
granted he says the destruction of our
cities from the air has long since
turned germany into an arena of war and
yet we find it inconceivable
impermissible to think that germany
should
ever again so it could ever become could
ever become such an arena in the true
sense
and our propaganda has a curious way of
warning the foe
against incursion upon our soil our
sacred german soil as if that would be
some grisly atrocity
our sacred german soil as if anything
was still sacred about it as if it had
not long ago been desecrated again and
again
by the immensity of our rape of justice
and did not lie naked
both morally and in fact before the
power of divine judgment
let it come says man and then he says
when he thinks about wurzburg
and all the beautiful gem-like cities of
germany being turned into power and ash
this is terrible
he said but i but i cannot allow myself
to forget
that terrible though german defeat is it
is nothing compared to the thought the
horror of german victory
he's willing to come to terms with he
seems almost to invite something
that is a judgment against which no
appeal can ever be
made it's finished there's going to be
no myth this time
that we could have won if we'd hung on a
couple more years
that we were stabbed in the back by the
jews they certainly weren't by then
that the the the crescent as homosexuals
and communists and uh
pacifists undermined german morale no no
no no excuses this time it's over you
have conclusively lost
and we can now begin to reconstruct
german democracy
and culture and civilization which we
did don't let it be
forgotten uh in his book which i greatly
admire refers to a war of annihilation
i think he should have not employed that
word did not annihilate germany
british and american soldiers did not
commit atrocities against german
civilians hitler's former allies in the
red army
committed the most appalling atrocities
on german civilians but if you lie down
with the devil in that way this is what
you have to expect
we have everything to be proud of it
seems to me
in the resilience of the german people
who re-emerge from the rubble
very quickly uh without self-pity
without resentment without conspiracy
theories to begin in this task of
reconstructing not only
germany but also a europeanized germany
and a democratic europe in which
germany still has private place
uh as a centerpiece um in economics in
in culture in publishing and democracy
uh and it's something of which we're all
all of us consider ourselves friends of
the german people
rightly proud justifiably proud i do not
myself believe that without i won't call
it a war of annihilation but without an
annihilating
conclusive incontestable utter victory
of the kind that sherman imposed on
slavery that when the slaves were freed
from the camps
that when the clemers could walk again
in the street without the yellowstone
there wasn't that dead feeling of
liberation
heinrich bell in his closing letter to
his sons the one he wanted them to read
after he died his
posthumous letter to his sons one of the
greatest german authors of all time i
think says
my boys you will as you grow up always
know
what to think of any of your fellow
countrymen according as to whether they
describe
april 1945 as the month of german
liberation or german defeat
never forget this neither should we now
in closing i've got to say two things
about
anthony's book that gravely disappointed
me that he didn't mention himself
one i think that he should not have said
that it would have been right for the
air crews of the american and british
air forces to refuse to obey these
orders i think it is of the first
importance in the time of warfare
uh when the when civilian and democratic
government is not just in command but at
stake where its existence is at stake
that the civilian and elected
governments have the right to assume
that they know the largest strategic
picture and that their
order their orders will be obeyed and i
think the suggestion that there should
have been a mutiny in the middle of a
war against the third reich
is an immoral one and i think you should
withdraw it
i think it was entirely right for those
orders to be obeyed whatever the doubts
may have been
because it was it is not the place of
officers to take to take the place
of members of parliament and the british
cabinet
and then i'm going to have to read a
chapter which
excuse me a paragraph that i think
disfigures the book
uh and i'll just quickly do this and i
think then it really will be time for me
to end my
hostage taking of this audience um
anthony says
a surprise attack on a civilian
population aimed at causing maximum hurt
shock disruption and terror that comes
to see
very little difference in principle
between the raf's operation gamora
or the usaf atom bomb attacks on
hiroshima and nagasaki
and the destruction of the world trade
center in new york by terrorists on 11th
of september 2001
and this latter prescinding from
differences in scale and the
drama of the target is no different in
turn from terrorist bombings carried out
in madrid by basque separatists
surrendered by the ira
all these all these there's an amalgam
here terrorist attacks or atrocities
consisting in deliberate mass murder
civilians to hurt and coerce
the society they belong to to say that
the principle underlying 911 hamburg and
hiroshima is the same as to say
that the same moral judgment applies to
all three i'm sorry i won't pass that i
won't take that
uh the the terrorist organization which
is also
a criminal multinational corporation a
secret society
uh a fanatical religious cult and many
of things run by osama bin laden is
replying to no offense committed against
itself
it's not attempting to protect or defend
its own civilians
uh it can is concerned with other
people's civilians only to the extent
that
only to the extent only to the extent
that casualties in their ranks may be
maximized to the greatest possible
extent and has not even a jot or tittle
of justification
on any strategic matter i think it's
quite indecent to mention these things
in the same breath i think spurious
moral equivalence is the thing that must
at all costs be avoided in this argument
and i do hope that that sentence isn't
in the book when it's published
in germany very well thank you very much
comrades and
thank you anthony for putting up with me
this one
oh yeah okay okay so i can hold this
like that
am i gonna use this next okay
okay thanks
thank you for being wired well i have a
caring
caring voice
like dr evil yes thank you
is it is it echoing is that okay rich
i'm sorry
okay well i i think it would be only
fair to to
start this the next section of this by
by offering the floor back to anthony if
you would like to respond to
to um the last couple of points that
christopher made um
and then i have a question that i wanted
to ask both of you and then and then we
certainly can open it up to
questions from the floor well there are
a number of things in that that very
rich and eloquent uh um
presentation by um hitch there that i'd
love to respond to but i'll pick out
two uh which i think uh perhaps the most
significant
the first is um on the question of the
annihilating attack the the definitive
defeat of germany the fact that
the germans must know that they've been
you know
smashed and they've got to start
absolutely from from scratch
and one one thing that struck me as i
was working on the book was the fact
that
roosevelt and churchill had signed only
very shortly afterwards to rescind
a plan that had been put forward by the
secretary of the treasury here in the
united states
in roosevelt's administration a man
called henry morgenthau
this is known as the morgenthau plan and
this plan was devised against the
background of
much discussion most of it which went on
here in in the us
about what to do about germany after the
war and these discussions were of
all kinds they ranged from very extreme
um ideas that uh
you know the german people should be
sterilized so there won't be any more of
them in future
uh to uh let's take all the german
children out of germany
put them into australia and places where
they could learn cricket so that when
they went back to england they were you
know back to germany they behaved
themselves
the idea was to try and extirpate
prussian militarism
to try to get rid of the culture that
had twice plunged
the world into war in a single
generation morgathau's idea was
that germany should be de-industrialized
the war should be handed over to france
and
the netherlands and luxembourg and so on
and it should be divided into two purely
aggregate
agrarian countries purely agricultural
countries
now roosevelt and and churchill signed
this but they were told by their
respective foreign
secretaries henry stinson and anthony
eden what a very very bad idea this was
eden pointed out to churchill
that a reconstructed germany was going
to be vital for europe
it was going to be vital as a bulwark
against the soviet union because that
was going to be the next big threat
and it was vital as a trading partner
anyway for britain itself
and so the the idea was torn up
but the fact that it was put forward at
all the fact that it got as far as it
did in the debate
is speaks volumes really about
a whole background of opinion that
had its influence indirectly on the
conduct of the bombing campaigns
now just before i get to the second
point that uh
i need to address the remember this that
we're talking here about one aspect of
the bombing campaign well it happened to
be more than fifty percent of what the
raf did and that is area bombing
deliberate attacks on civilians to
massacre and terrorize civilians
that aspect of the bombing campaign was
fueled by the sense that when you bomb a
city
you don't only bomb the people in it but
you bomb the schools
the libraries the concert halls the
archives the monuments
the art galleries the places where they
make violins
places where they record music in other
words you bomb the culture
in the book i call it culture side the
idea that you could
exterminate the
the culture as well as the people in
order to smash it and and
start afresh and this ties in very much
with with um
um hitch's idea about an annihilating
defeat that would
make it possible for them to to start
refresh and to do it right and i think
as many people did during the war itself
meant in the seed of chaos that
wonderful pamphlet that very britain
wrote
she makes the point that there are
plenty of people in germany who weren't
supporters of the nazis
you know as it says the the city of
hamburg had been
the center of opposition to nazism and
yet it suffered the first
very big attack annihilating attack that
our obama command had mounted and so
what was happening was that the people
who were going to be needed and the
resources that were going to be needed
the clinics and schools and books and
music halls that were going to be needed
in the reconstruction effort afterwards
were being destroyed in the process and
so
one has to one has to put a question
mark over that that's the first point
the second point i must take up the
direct challenge about my 9 11 analogy
i was trying there very carefully by
making the point about pre-sending from
from other uh considerations on which by
the way i agree absolutely with which
there's a very big difference between
the british and the raf that was
carrying out that policy
uh in in 1943 1944 45
and osama bin laden and his um
criminal fraternity carrying out the 911
attack of course there is that goes
without saying but the point that i
wanted to make was this
that if you think it is a bad thing that
anybody should try to
kill and terrorize civilians
non-combatants
in order to coerce their government or
to do harm to their
polity by carrying out an attack of that
kind
then you've got to be consistent and
you've got to recognize that
that on that particular point there is a
comparability between
deliberately and systematically
attacking civilians in cities
as we did in germany and japan during
the war so i'm going to stick with that
argument
christopher do you want to follow on
that very
quickly yes if if the bombing or indeed
if the war aim
in general uh because it would have been
consistent with precision bombing as
well
had been to impose the morganthan plan i
don't think it would possibly be
defensible
um so i simply in a way once a signal
agreement with anthony
about that except that it was not the
policy it was very i think it was
actually disowned before the
intervention of surrounding eden and
others because in my memory of reading
the churchill
roosevelt correspondents in of their
meeting in quebec and so anyone can
check this if they wish it's the quebec
meeting
it's discussed roosevelt says this is
what morgenthau thinks
what do you think churchill says sounds
like a good idea to me they go on rather
uneasily
and i think it reads to me like a
competition which is which of them is
going to be the first to say
actually did we just agree to that or
not churchill is at any rate the first
he says it sounds to me
i remember his words he says immoral and
unchristian i don't see what's
unchristian about mass murder i have to
say but um
but there you go that's how some people
talk um
anyway it it would not would have been
also by the way a very
very much stiffer and wider opposition
in britain and america
to this politically and for the
excellent reason that what it really is
the morgantown plan is a replay of the
west side treaty
the attempt to humiliate germany and
crush and squeeze its economy
about which lord cain's very famously
written his economic consequences of the
peace and
indeed an outcome for which many people
partly rightly
blame the rise of nazism in the first
place so i think any attempt to repeat
that blunder would have been met with a
very stern and public
and democratic opposition but as it
happens we didn't have to worry about
that
i'll just have to repeat a little more
sternly i think the point about
uh and you didn't take me up on mutiny
but maybe you didn't want to
oh mutiny on telling them that the our
guys should have disappeared oh right
yeah okay i'll respond just as i have a
point
because i can't believe that you would
play slide but on the um on the second
point um
uh which was i don't
know 911 yes look um
the the action of a non-state actor
who's announced in whose announced
policy
is not the rebellion against an empire
however crudely conducted which
is the case in your analogy with the
irish republican army or the basque
eta uh fighting however
criminally in their tactics for the for
what they conceive of as the sufferings
and
losses of their people but rather
announced in advance
by al qaeda and its supporters as the
attempt to impose
an empire in fact to do worse than that
to
rediscover and restore a lost and
vanished empire the caliphate
on everyone in the world to install a
universal dictatorship
and to show that its means and its ends
are exactly
symmetrical because it cares nothing for
the life of anyone who isn't a true
believer
this is not comparable to anything that
the royal air force did
it's just not to be mentioned in the
same breath and i've i've
totally run out of patience with all the
liberal and left excuses for this stuff
people who think that osama bin laden is
some voice of the oppressed
or cry of the unheard that's all balls
okay uh he wants east timor given back
to indonesia
uh the country the little country
already almost suffered genocide that
indonesian muslim hands he wasn't given
back
uh he his people blew up the un
ambassador to iraq
because he the great international civil
servant
sergio dimelio had overseen the
independence of east timor in its
transition they murdered him for that
as an infidel look what they did to
afghanistan pitch hits you you're right
fascism in the face with this guy and
yes i think his defeat should be
obliterating total final and humiliating
too
and i'd like a bit of applause for that
please just for the audience on the tv
thanks not enough applause sorry this is
washington
it is it's very very interesting what
hitch has done he said he
he he thinks that it was a good thing
that the defeat of germany was an
annihilating defeat um i agree with that
i think that the defeat
needed to be complete and definitive
we've seen in recent history that if you
don't
finish the job then it just comes back
to haunt you and makes things worse
later so
so he's right about that we're not
actually disagreeing on ends here but
we're talking about means
and in fact in the doctrine of just war
all the way back to aquinas and hugo
gracias and all the other people who
in our tradition have written about
these things there is this concept of
proportionality
if the aim is to defeat the enemy then
let's try and do it if you're going to
be as civilized and reflective about it
as you can be
even though war is a dirty business and
we've granted from
marks i made earlier on that there have
to be limits even in war
then you've got to try and do it in a
way which is consistent with that idea
of proportion
and what i mean by it is this if you
have a toothache you can cure it by
chopping of your head but that's a bit
extreme
you're trying to try and cure it by a
means that leaves the rest of you intact
if you can
and so so something some you know
considered way of of doing these things
is obviously the preferred option on the
point about the
so i'm drawing an analogy here between
the idea of
an annihilating defeat and using any
means
available to you to get that defeat in
order to make sure that
the monster isn't going to rise up again
and on that we're absolutely agreed
but what i want to try to do is to
discriminate in the literal sense of
that term is to look at a central fact
about something
i ask ourselves the question you've set
yourself a certain aim
is it a legitimate means to that end
to um pick a civilian population
to attack it to kill as many of them as
you can to frighten everybody else
by that terrifying attack on them is is
that ever
justified now there might be
circumstances there might be very very
extreme circumstances where
the great and and sometimes worthwhile
fig leaf of the
idea of collateral damage comes into
play here the idea that
there are very very regrettable
sincerely regrettable but unavoidable
casualties
of non-combatants of innocence of people
who aren't engaged
when a legitimate target is attacked but
i think one has to be
very careful about that one has to say
that has got to be the rare occasion
you've got to make a jolly good case uh
for claiming that it was unavoidable
that those people were hurt
and if you're doing something very
different from that if you're actually
targeting civilians in order to kill
and terrorize that in itself the
intrinsic quality of that act
no matter whether you think you've got a
declared war no matter whether it's
states that are the actors in the case
in other words a terrorist organization
has to be wrong if you think 911 was
wrong and it was it was an atrocity
then you've got to think that
systematically and deliberately
attempting to massacre civilians in any
circumstance
is an atrocity so i'm going to stick
with that point now i must pick up a
hitch on the on the um oh thank you
though
so the the the the point about mutiny
okay
um i i think uh with great respect hitch
misreads me that i didn't think that the
raf should
mutiny i quote in the book the uh um
phrase in the vermacht paybook which
said that if you think you've been given
an illegal order you can disobey it
and that it actually happened that were
marked soldiers i don't think very many
ss soldiers did but some
exempted themselves some actions that
they didn't agree with
uh and survived um now in in the case of
the the royal air force
uh personnel the usaf personnel i say
that
in an ideal world i say preface that
don't i say in an ideal situation
if these um airmen were asked um will
you go in for area bombing bombing
civilian populations or will you go for
uh tactical targets important military
industrial targets
that they should have opted for the
latter i didn't say they should mutiny
certainly not
and i grant also a number of things i
grant that they really believed with
with great justification that they were
engaged in a just war that they have the
support of the majority of their
populations these were young men putting
their lives on the line
it it moves me to think that 55 000
very very young men died in the sky over
germany in the royal air force
from from britain and the british empire
45 000 united states army air force
personnel died in the air a terrifying
awful death
and i have to comment because it is one
of the awful ironies of war it's the
sort of thing that each would would
appreciate maybe
that those 55 000 world air force
personnel died
in the process of killing 350 000
germans
german children and women and elderly
people and people who were
not directly engaged in act of combat
a ratio of seven to one what general
would uh
send his troops into battle if you
thought those were the odds
okay i think i've got to i mean unless
okay you could write me down uh ladies
and gentlemen if you like
i'm not quibbling but you you phrase the
question like this
under hard questions should airmen have
refused to carry out area bombing raids
yes
then the this then as you say your
reasoning follows but it's not
you don't preface it with that yes means
yes it seems to me
um and i think i would not have said it
i mean commander hitchens of blessed
memory
i can promise you did not join the royal
navy and sail around the world um
for his majesty the king in order to end
up running guns to stalin
which he ended up doing over the hump of
momansk and archangel
uh when the scandinavian coast was
entirely controlled by the um
luftwaffe the seas largely controlled by
the u-birds
very unpleasant job he thought it was
outrageous to be helping the stalin
regime to go but he did not i think
think well
this is so much against my conscience i
can't do it how could i have impeached
him if he had
well these might be questions for
another day i i think i'm glad on the
whole
that people decided that the british
government was a decent enough one to
have its orders obeyed even if
questionable things were being
done and like for instance a whole
number of other episodes in the
second world war possibly the sinking of
the french fleet at anchor when it was
not in aggressive mode that the british
did that were also to be
uh questioned that would make an
excellent moral exercise
um let me stop you just for a second
because i want to make sure that there
is time
okay so you have to say this is
precision bombing would have done an
awful lot of damage to the german war
effort in dresden
there's no question about it and
probably more for arguably more than
area bombing did but the next day
precision bombing would have left the
same people in charge of dresden i'm
sorry to say and victor clamper would
have got
on that [ __ ] cattle track
the same because the order wouldn't have
been destroyed there wouldn't have been
total chaos the the utter destruction of
the state system and it's uh
now anyone who's seen the pictures of
those
even in german camps camps on german
soil relatively lenient
i'm at buchenwald in dakar the condition
of the people who as they were found
uh by vibration american soldiers can
see this people only got a few
more days to live at best they're all
dying i think
another few months of this war and they
would all have died
as so many of them did in poland and
hungary and elsewhere this also has to
be born in mining considering the
japanese empire and its hideous god king
uh every day that that country didn't
surrender i personally opposed to
hiroshima and nagasaki
i can tell you something that dr edward
teller once told me that it was his view
that there should have been a
demonstration bomb dropped and not the
use of it on civilian cities
but urgent questions are let off upon
because every day the japanese empire
goes on
thousands of its slaves are dying and we
have the
right and the duty to save them it seems
to me
so um i am sorry if that's not too much
but i i thought i couldn't not say that
this is urgent
and it's a terrible utilitarian calculus
shall you kill more germans to rescue
their slaves and their victims well
you could i suppose that you can compose
it by saying
if i if i pray this is what i would say
and i don't but
i would say well thank god we thank god
we didn't start this
could i trespass in everybody's patience
because there's a point not not to
disagree with it this time but just
a point to cognate what he's just said
there which is that
on the 28th of march 1945 churchill sent
a memo to
manchester charles portal who was the
head of the raf to say to him
the terror bombing of the german cities
that's his phrase the terror bombing
must now stop he said the uh the bombing
of dresden is a serious query against
raf behavior
it's very very interesting that he wrote
this this memo because at
certain points during the war he came
out tremendous speeches about you know
flattening with german cities
and on other occasions he had horrible
fits of
of conscience about it one occasion when
he left to his feet
watching footage of bombing of the royal
valley which was a heavily
industrialized area of germany
and said are we animals what are we
doing why are we doing this this is
right in the middle of the war
and that memory that he sent the 28th of
march was returned to him
by sir charles portal with a note saying
you can't write in me like this
and you're in effect accusing me of a
war crime you can't say this about us
you've got to rewrite this in milder
terms which churchill did
but the original memo was kept on fire
and was published by the official
historians of vomit command in 1960
webster and franklin
both of whom had had their very serious
doubts about the banning
uh the bombing campaign but what's
interesting about it is this
at the end of march churchill's
anxieties
which i suspect had been fueled
certainly by by anthony eden but also by
senior army officers who are getting to
and fro between
uh conquered parts of germany and back
to to london
and they're saying my god you ought to
see what's what's happened there and
what you know what we've done
and all those anxieties and in fact he
mentioned um
just that sort of reaction uh on the
part of uh of dreiberg
um but then within two weeks the first
of the concentration camps was liberated
by allied troops
now in gamma bergen-belsen dachau
and buchenwald and the footage the
newsreel footage coming out of germany
showing
british tommies and bulldozers uh moving
huge piles of emaciated bodies into mass
graves
that so horrified the world quite
rightly so
the whole world was so disgusted and
enraged by
what we were seeing coming out of
germany that the debate
about the bombing was of course and i
think properly
dwarfed by it it's one reason why it's
taking so long really for
for people to be able to get enough
perspective to separate things out you
know like that game of pick up sticks
you get all the different
separate them out and just look at the
that part of the bombing campaign the
area bombing campaign
just by itself and to examine it in our
own consciences
about it march 45 is a funny time for
churchill to develop scruples
especially if what i said about the
final solution
and i believe i'm writing saying that
nowhere in any one of his histories
any one volume of this multi-volume
history of the second world war is the
final solution mentioned
i had a feeling i rather larger mission
from churchill and historiography
i had a feeling i wouldn't have to do a
whole lot up here to get the
conversation going
um so i'm not i won't ask any questions
but but i
open the floor up to anyone in the
audience um can we start right there
um and then we'll come down to the front
row right here
and then we'll go and then we'll go over
to this side right here
so those will be the first three and
then we'll keep going please mr hitchens
yes apart from the morality of it
do you think that terrorizing civilian
populations works
um well i think this was liberating the
civilian population in part
i mean i don't we don't know how
terrorized people were we know
that the nazis kept a constant watch on
people who appeared to be celebrating or
fraternizing with advancing western
russian troops
hang them from the lampposts some of you
may have seen the extraordinary film
uh uh downfall recently made in germany
downfall the regime kept on
acting pornographically till the very
very end and once
can't overlook the facts it's mentioned
the word terrorizing that hitler's
intention was not to terrorize the
german people but if possible to have
them destroyed as unworthy of national
socialism
he wanted a holocaust if you like for
the germans
uh that seems to me it can't be left out
of the moral account i don't believe
we're trying to terrorize the population
i think we're making it clear that
hitler had brought them
into a trap from which there was no
escape
and that that the revenge upon this this
maniac this monster
would be something that the world would
never ever ever forget
i think the burden of your question to
be uh about the
whether or not the the bombing had the
effect really of of buckling morale
and um it's a sort of an oddity in a way
given the fact that the
morale of the british people was uh um
stiffened
uh in fact as well as in propaganda
about by the bombing
um that the conductors of the raf
bombing campaign or the harris in
particular
shouldn't have realized that there might
be a you know sort of counterproductive
effect
um and it's it's really quite
interesting to see
that that in fact happened in germany it
certainly played into joseph goebbels
hands because he was able to use
the uh the area bombing campaign as a
as an argument to the german people for
resisting
saying you know they're acting in this
barbaric way you can see they've no
hobart
no hoes by as far as they're concerned
they're going to do anything to us so
we've really got to hang in there
he was cheered in the streets of berlin
this is joseph goebbels being cheered in
the streets of berlin
and you know berliner schnauzer and all
the rest of they weren't very happy
about the nazis
nazis either until um harris's so-called
battle of berlin which started in late
1943 went through to the early spring of
1944
um in attempting to break the spirit of
the berliners
and it did anything but so um your
question
is uh is a very interesting one the hope
that it would
force the the german population to turn
on its government and tell them to
sue for peace was that was an empty one
next question is here can i just suggest
that that you address questions to both
of them and and
i'm sure both of them will pick up on
them this is particularly to professor
grayling
with regard to the question of hiroshima
and nakasaka
namely no the argument one years
which is i find at least partially
persuasive
is that these use of atomic bombs
could be justified in reducing the
casualties
for in in the war against japan
because they uh shortened the war
i mean it certainly seems clear they did
shorten the war the u.s was was be
getting prepared
for a mass invasion with in anticipating
you know perhaps a hundred thousand
casualties and who money who knows how
many
japanese casualties so what would you
say about the calculus the moral
calculus
in that decision obviously
you know all together maybe a hundred
thousand were killed in the two bombings
but is that still dying too
um
i mean can when make the case that that
uh preempted you know maybe half a
million being killed
well i would in order to accept that
point we'd have to accept the premise
that
the japanese weren't ready to make peace
on the morning of the 6th of august
before the first bomb went off
and that now there's a very very wide
consensus now that's just not the case
but for months beforehand they've been
making overtures for
discussions about peace and that there
were other
motives on the american side for not
agreeing to talks
they wanted i mean there seems to be a
counter argument to the point about
saving lives
to keep the war going until the bombs
were ready you ask yourself the question
why did they drop
two bombs then one might have been
enough well the answer is they were two
different kinds of bombs
they kept cities relatively unbombed in
order to see what the effect would be
turn down the idea of doing a
demonstration and also for months
beforehand you know solitary b-29s
were sent over uh japanese cities very
very high up thirty thousand feet
twenty-five thousand feet to drone
around a little bit over the city and
then go away again
so that the japanese population get used
to having these solitary what they
thought reconnaissance aircraft
overhead in fact the japanese called
them mr b it's a harmless bombers that
came overhead and then went away
so that on the morning of the 6th of
august and there was a solitary droning
b-29 above hiroshima nobody took any
notice nobody was in an airway shelter
or anything else
when that bomb went off and there is a
chilling description
by by hersh i think talking about seeing
a line of soldiers with their
hands on the shoulder of the soldier in
front all blind because they've all been
looking up at the bomber when the flash
happened and their eyes were turned
to liquid and ran down their cheeks like
tears
christopher your point um would be met
by
a demonstration bomb of the kind that
the famous doctor i would tell her told
me he would
he had favored the same effect could
have been produced on the 5th of august
or earlier
um if other things being equal the
only reason i can think and i've never
heard a justification for nagasaki as a
matter of fact
is this because the the argument that it
shortened the war was never made in 1945
in any cabinet discussion we have all
the papers now nobody said let's do it
to shorten the war
some appear to have said let's do it to
impress joseph stalin which hey
is the reason we've destroyed president
already stalin seems to require a lot of
immolated cities for his
self-satisfaction um the
the other is possibly to uh deter the
soviet union
um advancing into japanese islands
but i think not until 1948 does anyone
come up with the excuse well it
shortened the war
so all of you who are out of the pacific
theater should be grateful you've got
home early it's it's a bogus argument
unfortunately
um the only the other thing one could
say is well
it's it's completely annihilating
there's going to be no one in the
japanese office of court after the
surrender saying
ah but perhaps you know we could have a
comeback one day
the the empire will rise again they know
they know that's it
you really have lost this time again
this is an argument that i find
myself very uncomfortable even
rehearsing because i'll quantify will
then possibly wicked but
these are psychological effects we take
for granted that we didn't have in our
arsenal all the time
finally not in the arsenal of the raf or
the usaf were rocket bombs
v1s and v2s which started falling on
london to a considerable extent
in 1945 and in fact it's universally
agreed the british morale at that point
was likely to crack because people
thought it was nearly over
and they couldn't stand they thought it
was starting again and this time not
bombers that could be shot down
but rocket bombs exploding without
warning you read steven spender's
diaries of being a fireman in london at
that point and elsewhere
all that stuff about british pluck and
so on i mean i'm wedded to it okay and
believe me
but it's very very overdone the people
were really
really flaking now at that point you say
well what else
look we know the nazis are trying for
horror weapons what's on the next damn
rocket
what do we know is coming maybe it'll be
gas
maybe it'll be germs we don't know what
we do know is we're going to flatten
anywhere which can launch one of those
for those damn rockets
and we're entitled to anything that's
how people are going to think if they're
fought in this way
this was germany not germany but hitler
urging suicide on his people let me add
a couple of things to what
you just said there um maybe right this
point about the shortening the war thing
was the post factory justification
it did happen though that truman wrote a
letter on the ninth of august the day of
the second bomb
in which he said uh um we will take all
measures necessary to
uh you know reduce the number of our own
military casualties so that that point
was put that early
in a letter which in other respects is
full of weasel expressions like
i'm doing my utmost to ensure that there
are no you know we minimize civilian
casualties and so on this was written on
the 9th of august
so so there is that point um which is
right you know the
the the germans didn't build big bombers
what they did was they concentrated
their efforts on
building guided missiles it was teo raw
adorno one of the
one of the pluses on our side in this
exchange absolutely who said um
you can tell that the human race has got
cleverer over time but not wiser because
of the development from the spear into
the guided missile well
the first guided missile was was fired
off in the summer of 1944 was kept in
reserve for when the
invasion happened and then there was
this summer campaign summer and into the
early autumn
of 1944 that the v1s and v2s were coming
over
causing uh devastation in london
particularly and
one or two other places the v1 the
doodlebug you could hear it
and then when the engine cut out you
knew it was going to form everybody held
their breaths
but the v2 you couldn't hear you didn't
know it was coming
until it exploded and the old lady lives
across the road for me and
i talk in my book about the bomb site
across the road from my house and right
next to it
is a lady now in her late 80s who was in
that house
one day when the v1 fell a v2 rather
fell a couple of blocks away
and she tells this story about how she
was standing at the window
at the kitchen sink looking through the
window and her little sun was playing on
the lawn outside
and this terrific explosion went off as
you realize it was a v2 so she ran out
to see if her son was okay and he was
absolutely fine
but she wasn't because the window had
been blown in she was streaming blood
and her little son was traumatized by
the vision of this woman streaming blood
screaming at him and running like this
with her arms held wide so you can just
imagine how absolutely awful
it is but the v uh attack
had peated out more or less by the
ultimate 1944
partly because it was interdicted there
were attacks on the launch sites
but also because the just the number
that the germans had of them
wasn't very great and it's an
interesting fact that in the autumn of
1944 arthur harris
got back command of bomber command it
had been under eisenhower's
uh charge since before the d-day uh
landings
and had done a fantastic job which
harris always claimed he could never do
of tactical bombing of supplies and
the german army in france and rail heads
and bridges and so on
and he got it back and between the
autumn of 1944
and the 25th of april 1945 when the
bombing campaign was stood down
arthur harris had dropped more bombs on
germany than in the whole of the war
beforehand
and he had a list of cities and they
included gems like fort simon
hildesheim and wurzburg and others that
were bombed and the people who lived and
could not understand why because he
could
because he could that's exactly the
point the next question is this
gentleman here in the white shirt
and then we're going to go up to the
back for a question after that
i'd like to make two brief factual
points first one
both of you mentioned that hamburg was
the center of the german working class
the implication being that a lot of good
people died in the fire bombing of
hamburg
i think it's worth mentioning in this
connection that hamburg also was the
home of police battalion 101
which is described by christopher
browning in this herring description of
how the mass killing of jews took place
the killing of women children
uh by mass shootings thousands of uh of
victims being shot by these good people
from hamburg every day
now the second point is more important
uh
according to the man in charge of german
war production spare
uh there was a degrading effect as a
result of the
area bombing of german cities and spare
gives
figures that so many more planes could
have been produced and so many more
tanks could have been produced and so
forth i'm not prepared to argue that
this is decisive
that this is a matter of and justifying
means and so forth
but i think it should become part of the
moral calculus and therefore it is wrong
simply to say
uh the area bombing was uh
at no utility at all possibly it was
even counterproductive and so forth
the facts are it had some effect and
that should be taken into account
anthony um on that second point i i
think as
you know when spear was in prison in
prison before the the nuremberg trials
he was invited
by um an allied commission to come and
talk to them about production during the
war
and he astonished them by saying that
until the end of 1944
uh production was on the up he made the
point
to an audience that wanted to hear it
that um it wouldn't it wasn't rising as
fast as he would
light yes that takes account of that
point but the fact of the matter is that
it was rising
he complained that hitler never allowed
him to put the economy on a total war
footing
because hitler had this anxiety about
what had happened in 1919 when the
german economy couldn't provide
cigarettes and flower pots and things
like that to the german
and people who were annoyed about it
because
lots of shortages occur because of this
transfer of productive capacity
to other ends and so he never allowed it
and it turned out
never to be necessary anyway because of
the enormous resources that were
available
and it was the bottleneck things the oil
the the coal
uh that the transport that uh in the end
scuppered it and it was in january 1945
that shibea wrote to hitler and said the
war is over from the production point of
view because i just now can't get the
resources together to do it
um in in the book by the way i quote uh
how the germans
dealt with with bombing damage i talk in
particular about the thousand bomber
raid on cologne in 1942
and how many millions of cigarettes and
sheets and pints of milk and loaves of
bread
were on the autobahns going into cologne
within days of the
of the bombing rate how short of time it
took to rehouse people
partly because the germans knew that
since they were going to start the war
they made preparations for it very early
beginning 1935-36
but also because they had these massive
manpower resources
that never affected their their military
capacity
on the day that the war ended in europe
the day that berlin fell
there were 10 million men of military
age
in the wehrmacht between the ages of 18
and 35 all with boots on
and all with guns in their hands but you
do say
it's important i bet you personally
regardless beer as a
pathological liar um he was always
trying to please different audiences but
he did say
after the bombing of hamburg he said
another half dozen such raids would
[ __ ] germany's war production
that's what he thought then for this
subjective and he later discovers that's
not true
so he could have been panicked it might
have been worth trying to stampede a few
other people
a mention of these uh staunch fellows in
their jack woods
though it compels me to say again
shapiro's empire
of production which included i think i'm
writing saying the factories that built
the
rocket weapons and other places was a
slave empire these were not germans
working
they were slaves from russia and poland
and yugoslavia and greece and elsewhere
i'm in favor of the liberation of slaves
okay whatever it takes
and i think you may it can be something
you have to undertake in a hurry
you're certainly morally obliged to
undertake it
and those whose manpower and well-being
all the cigarettes you can get
so depend upon slavery have made a pact
which they'll upon which they may be
called
to witness sorry to sound like a
preacher but their their
their bloody well is and those slaves
were liberated before they could be
exterminated or before they could be
worked to death and i think this really
must be part of
what you call the calculus sir
so i'm alerted by if i may i'm terribly
sorry alerted by a phrase
um whatever it takes that phrase that
it's uses there
uh you know we agree means necessary as
the traditional slogan yeah
by any means by any means necessary um
and also by any means effective i've got
to say because
um somebody sent me an email shortly
after my book came out in the uk
a professor of economics and andrews
university and he said to me uh
i find your book incredibly interesting
i'd just like to let you know that uh
you know there's quite a bit of
discussion about what would have
happened if the
whole bombing effort of the royal air
force and the united states army air
force
had been focused on industrial and
military targets
if the raf had really backed up the
united states army air force on this one
he said the war could have been two
years shorter if they'd done that
that's a fantastic thought if if correct
you know but of course it's supposed
to surmise about it but it suggests
something which is
that the area bombing the attacks on the
civilian populations
were not part of what was necessary they
were not necessary
to winning the war and that in a way if
it's you know if any sense attaches to
the idea of
potentiating the degree of moral
criminality of an act
it just makes things worse that they
weren't it wasn't really having any
that it was marginal and yet it caused
this huge number of casualties
i want to go up in the back um way up in
the back on the left
in fact we scuppered a gentleman here
because i i interrupted i'm so sorry
this gentleman here with
the beard well we'll come we'll come
right back we'll come back to him next
but go up go up there
yeah uh yes the veterans history project
of the library of congress
houses uh a somewhat incredible
collection of at this point 40
000 oral histories and more than half of
those are world war ii veterans
and i have yet to hear
a testimony or read a letter or
manuscript
that has any compunction about the
dropping of the atomic bomb
to a man every veteran sees this
as bringing a war to an end and i think
it is quite interesting
to seem to have discounted that from all
of our discussions
it's one thing to look at the documents
and to look at the leaders it's quite
another thing to look at the opinions of
the men who are expected to put their
lives on the line and to actually
execute
that war okay but it's not
unlike the huge um population explosion
of jews in france
in during the second world war i mean i
mean by that to say
i'm sure you've had the same experience
ever been to a french farmhouse that
didn't shelter at least six jews
i have not there must have been a
gigantic growth of jewish population on
division it seems to me
likewise i hate to say this i have never
met
an american serviceman who is anywhere
near the pacific theater who has not
told me
that on the 7th of august 1945 his
regiment was scheduled to go
into the home islands of japan they all
seem to believe it now
i wasn't there and i i'm not one to want
to quarrel with um
the guys in uniform but it can't be true
and the argument was not made to them at
the time hey we've shortened the war you
can go home this is why we've done it
was not made so 1947
where at i believe it was very useful as
was the opening of
brookenvald and dakao and neongama
instilling any conscience that people
might have had about what they've done
ah well then now i see
why it was necessary i think it's um i
think one has to distrust this stuff
very much can i tell you that
just before i came across the pond um i
on the same day received a telephone
call
message on my answer phone and a letter
and the telephone call
was from an elderly gentleman who said
i'm phoning to say
i've just finished your book i was an
air crew and i was a sergeant navigator
in
world level bomber command and ever
since the war
i've i've suffered in silence
the sense of terrible guilt of what we
did i felt it then i felt it ever since
i've never really been able to
articulate it
and here it is being articulated and i'm
just phoning to thank you
and i mean to get a message like that
when you've written a book is it's very
moving
and i i've brushed the tear from my eye
and i opened the letter that was lying
on my desk and it said
you bastard how do you say this about
our brave men who did this
that wasn't the only letter i got but
there are always two sides to the story
and sometimes i and then i think to
myself why is it that um
that the person who wrote the letter uh
who was angry with me for having written
the book
uh and who's all therefore ever since
the war the woman in question was an
82 82-year-old ex-woman's auxiliary air
force
officer in fact she had seen the planes
going off and some of them not coming
back and that's one reason why she was
so angry because
she saw she witnessed the you know
the sacrifice from from the british side
of the story
and why she never had to say anything
was never called upon to to justify what
she was part of or
or what had happened because there was a
consensus about it
whereas he felt we'd won a victory with
defeated a terrible enemy who had to be
defeated
i was part of that but at the same time
you know
you read those accounts of airmen who
could feel the heat from hamburg and
from berlin and dresden in their
aircraft from 20 000 feet
and see the glow from hundreds of miles
away as they flew back again afterwards
who never said anything because they
felt that to do it would be some kind of
betrayal even of themselves
and that's one reason for silence anyway
we have group captain leonard cheshire
and many many other veterans who took a
different view even at the time
as well since so um it's not in fact
a perfect correlation between being a
combatant and being a
an enthusiastic supporter of um arie
bombing we're coming up on nine o'clock
um
and uh and i want to give time for
people to you know either buy books
outside and talk
so um uh let me take two more questions
and and ask that they be brief and ask
that the responses be brief
but you will have a chance to talk to
each of them afterwards so if we don't
get to your question if you have a
receipt
yeah that was america well done
um here and here
okay yes yeah okay right sorry
thanks a lot you made a compelling uh
contextual arguments against the bombing
tactic
and i wanted to play devil's advocate
real quick if germany and japan had come
across a similar capacity to do civilian
bombings to the u.s and the uk
wouldn't be a handicap to not be able to
use the same tactic against
germany and japan prior to them actually
doing it to the us and the uk
so if uh your opponent can sucker punch
you wouldn't it be
wrong to not be able to sucker punch
them before they did it to you
well i i think it the there's something
that lies behind the question that i
that i have to take issue with which is
that um
if the point in question were trying to
preempt
their capacity to do that to you to do
an arrow bombing campaign against you
that the right thing to do would be to
attack that capacity to attack their
aircraft and airfields and bomb-making
factories and so on
but uh to attack their civilians in
their cities would have been entirely
the wrong strategy
because it would have left that affected
their ability to do it to you so
so that's my response e.m foster wrote a
great essay
it's reprinted in two cheers for
democracy it was actually delivered as a
bbc broadcast
in the early days of the struggle saying
um
he was very anti-militarist but he said
before we consider what germany might do
to us we should consider what it's
already done to germany the wreckage of
german culture the the
smashing of the universities the
emigration of the genius germany not not
by any means all the jewish but a lot of
it
which very probably meant that they
hugely [ __ ] their
ability to use physics for warfare but
we knew that they were working on it
and it's the only reason that men like
einstein would never have dreamt of
prostituting his talent in this way
and meals were willing to work on it too
was because of the dread that they might
get it first well now
if you're in a situation where you don't
know you know you know heisenberg is
still in germany you
you know he's a great physicist you
don't know how much resources he has
well you may you you have to consider
yourself entitled to try anything it
seems to me
it would be irresponsible be impeachable
not to do so
we don't know how close they came not
very they were defeated products they
were fascists
fascism is irrational and
self-destructive we can be grateful for
that
i've been lovingism sir uh
the problem i'm having with the moral
position on this is that
when you take the moral position it's
very difficult to
attack it with logic when one deals with
it's regrettable because uh it's
regardless because
we were enraged it's regrettable because
we wanted to send a message of revenge
it's regrettable because we wanted to
make stalin think
twice uh it's a very utilitarian
argument
but it seems to me to posit the moral
position
which is you know either with it or
you're not
is that the deliberate targeting of
civilians
whether from the air or from the ground
or for torture
or holding them in communicado for years
or whatever
uh suspension of habeas corpus and all
of these things
can be done for utilitarian reasons but
it seems to me
that when you take those positions and
you use them you are
sailing from the shores of civilization
and there's no return
that uh it's very hard then to draw
those lines
so you can't think of any circumstances
in which pacifism would be an immoral
position
well in fact i can but when i do that i
realize that i am
creating a hole in in a wall i'm
breaching
the logic i'm taking a position that may
in fact be immoral
for some other reason that i believe it
overrides
the situation
anthony do you want to oh i just make a
tangential point
which is that the point of raising the
moral
issue at all even if it's post-facto and
even if it's a long time afterwards
seems to me to actually pack much more
of a punch than people realize
i mean i wonder whether it isn't the
case that some military commander
somewhere or much more to the point some
politician making a decision about
going to war or doing something during
the course of a war
doesn't reflect what will happen in 30
or 40 years time when some meddling
philosopher comes along and says
what you did was bad and ruins his
reputation
and that might be it probably isn't it
might be a constraint on some people
sometimes
and uh you know the hope the struggle is
you know here we all are we're in the
in the in the raging seas of uh
controversy
and history and we're trying to hold the
candle the lighted candle up as high as
possible
and and that's the point you know having
the debate at all
is one way of trying to save something
back from
uh our uh great endeavor to be civilized
in times of emergency and having it at
the time in london in the press in
parliament in the churches yeah that's
not
terrible it would be nice if the germans
were able to read that discussion would
be very nice they ought to have it
themselves
alas wasn't the nature of the enemy that
we were confronting
you have been a terrific audience um
thank you for your patience um i trust
those positions
well if you let you let me continue
i trust that's because you found it
interesting and thought provoking and
and and engaging which i certainly did
as well